[Music]
all right what's not people don't mind
this this is my toothpick you just
finished eating dinner starting a vlog
late because well it's been a while
since I've logged I feel like vlog
intermittently in the past couple weeks
but I haven't really had time to edit
because I've been working on danger boys
a lot and the Edit has come to a finish
almost we're doing like minor tweaks
them but most of it's done the trailers
cut the pieces that it's cut and now
we're just kind of guys now we're trying
to figure out what to do with the next
steps by anyways enough danger boys I
feel like I've talked about danger boys
for like a long time now and I'm done
with it until we do something else with
it now
until we figure out what to do with the
next recently I've been working on some
other stuff for exit matcha and some big
products coming up with that too as well
so a lot of filmmaking marketing
directing video stuff in my life right
now
not enough vlog content making right now
I'm sorry you guys have been kind of
left with the lack of vlogs in the
recent weeks so yeah jump them back on
this train now and hopefully we can keep
it going
me and Isaac it's we just finished jakie
news filming or oh I finish taking these
filming because TIFF is still out doing
the last six episodes because I have to
leave early to pick up Isaac there he is
he's over there what are you doing
you're watching memes and you you are
such a preteen teenager kid big kid
toddler
Isaac has been watching memes and that
is definitely a true sign of him
aging out of the previous stage of being
McKidd to me oh he said I don't watch
meantime I've never got into the whole
like enjoying social media like a actual
like source of entertainment and for me
it's more of like updates with friends
and like things I care about but I'd
never stay on it long enough for me to
consider like true entertainment where
I'm just like on it for hours it's
usually I'm sitting on the toilet or I'm
bored in a doctor's office or something
I'm just waiting and it's like
transitional entertainment it's never me
it's never like this like you're not
transitioning into anything right now
right you're not like waiting well you
are waiting now you're waiting for me to
he's waiting for me to shut up and stop
talking for this intro of this
particular blog that you're watching
right now so that we can start gaming
because I told him we should make a
gaming video because I don't know we
just been playing a lot of Minecraft but
where the games are even playing Super
Smash Bros I think we should play Super
Smash black Super Smash Bros tonight
yeah yeah cuz that we've done minecraft
they seen minecraft two times so I think
we're we're good on on that right yeah
we should do Super Smash Bros cos V cuz
cuz we did too much of Minecraft
too much minecraft Super Smash Bros okay
got it
so I heard from money then you said that
you might want to have a youtube channel
hmm is that true yes yes what what do
you guys think what do you think I think
I should yeah so it's only gaming only
gaming's that's her brand it's to get a
gaming thing you're not interested in
flogging not really not really why it's
flogging like an old person thing you
think no no there's another play games
I think noticed that teeth had tick tock
downloaded on her phone and then Isaac
what did you think she's pinky she's
cringy why is that Cringer why is it
cringy to have tick tock on your phone
cuz people
tik-tok are very kinky they make cringy
videos is YouTube cool yeah YouTube for
ya okay what makes YouTube cooler than
tick tock you get or watch videos that
are longer and people don't do this and
do this and play you keeps hitting my
shoulder but it's okay
you're like it's a love thing stuff and
then I have play music in the background
you gotta watch people game people
playing on game a word you like to use a
lot of times especially when playing
video games is the word trihard would
you say people don't take talk are try
hards
no then what and then what what do you
this isn't trihard no no okay so what
what is it about it that is cringy I
don't know cuz I don't watch I've never
I don't have tick-tock on my phone with
your channel so no vlogs purely gaming
videos what kind of games would you have
to do games on the switch games on the
Xbox and yeah like games on rich contain
many Xbox ok watch games um win Krypton
this Nintendo Swick Super Smash Bros
cuphead cool Cup I like I love cup head
it's so frustrating but it's so fun and
smooth Super Smash Bros is really fun
too and frustrating in a way where I can
never win because I I'm just not as good
as you are you just smash me every
single time you have like YouTube
channel concepts like ideas names you
know releasing release dates marketing
strategies you have it all planned out
logos merch designs you know enemy yeah
yeah you have a the upload schedule
planned out and all that stuff to our
car planned out
intro sign out that stuff yeah yeah I
totally got all that yeah you don't have
to do all this so just have fun you
don't need to worry about that I'm just
playing with you but for real if you
really want to be a youtuber though
those are things I think modern-day you
know current youtubers do have to think
about eventually I hate thinking about
that stuff too though it's so it sucks
the fun out of making videos anyways
alright let's edit for this game
BAM oh yeah yours is way cool show that
mom super smash bros ultimate oh don't
they do that in the and then you get
real close and then like ultimate owe
all to me all to me so you want to go
donkey kong jungle yeah yeah like--on
coins my favorite donkey kong country
super nintendo best game ever so just
click the two things naturally on a pig
Donkey Kong okay yo mama and I like
doing the yellow Donkey Kong hair oh I
like suited Mario suited Mario oh this
is the classic Donkey converses Mario
it's like the classic na komm was the
villain before right like a original
original Mario game yeah
for original Donkey Kong game is these
two guys against each other and Donkey
Kong how do you even play this game it
oh my god oh wow
of course oh my god its lucky ball how
do you even know what you're doing I'm
just button smashing Peter get him get
him
so a is to a and y sub jump stop
blocking yeah get out of here
I beast laughed you
Oh what do I do what I do
all right get out of the way get out of
the way jump jump jump jump down what'd
you throw that it just explodes me for
no reason
get that it's from a you're cheating how
am i keeping because you keep using all
these power-ups I play my style of play
gameplay is to never use power-ups oh
yeah then I'm coming back for you dude
Donkey Kong never forgets oh are you so
strong why is Donkey Kong so strong I
mean why is mario so strong there you go
bang yeah out of here weakly oh I want
this sword how do you pick it up you
gotta punch it oh you and your stupid
troll man is getting out of you yeah
yeah little punk game
rematch okay so have you figured out
like channel damage or anything really I
can't I don't know this is what it's
like at all Wally online hold on let me
figure it out my moves first I haven't
figured him out yet
I'm fair to mug it stop stop playing
stop playing sobbing stops okay like hey
figure out I'm gonna try and trigger
things at hook you don't it's really
hard for me to figure out if you're
trying to hit me hi let me first please
out you're like killing me and you say
you just you see you dare you have to
counter you have to characters does not
even fair how'd you kill me what
happened not even know what happened
this guy is where's his hand coming from
where it was naked man why is there so
many fireballs any words its Mega Man's
power come on Wally Wally has no power
and except for a laser gun on his head
well it's like in the movie it's exactly
like in the movie night this is a wall I
told you is Wally
oh I'm just button mashing no power-ups
I don't know this character dude you
gotta go easy on me
cheerio I dunno man Oh Billy did I just
kill you no oh oh get him he's almost
dead just one more hit he's down
that lazy see that laser thing yeah yeah
yeah get outta here I'm you do it what
that's rigged what happened did I do
really good I think I'm just a really
good I like destroyed you oh it's
blowing my new favorite character or
what ah what is that thing on the ground
no I thought you're a stupid ball and
exploded in my face yeah you know it
doesn't it is does it the ball moly
let's heal you oh cool thanks ah I have
my swing punches OH
all right where'd you go where'd you go
you know who's that yellow guy right
there how'd you do that he split the
whole thing in half it's your mama
oh really No
Oh almost selling do it again maybe diet
by the same Thanks maybe I should make a
name called who's a daddy who Joe daddy
[Music]
well did I get a powerup go ahead
powerful just don't die don't die
did I win yeah I want what's the thing
that you're looking forward to the most
with the YouTube channel no you don't
know do you know how much work it takes
to run an YouTube channel yes you do how
much oh yeah how do you know it's like a
job it's a a job they see you guys see
you guys work did you make yourself yeah
and you can make yourself yeah I made
you I meet you oh where am I go to me
brawler's or meat store fighters or me
gunner
oh cool look a little a Bruce Lee and
then go to oh I see that's me you made
me even a most Asian eyes ever no I
created you're me right
Oh even has freckles like look I got
freckles in real life I created this me
yeah and I I said I saw the example that
and they look exactly like you well I
like the way I look but suppose like my
outfit
bring it full mouthful you know look Wow
stop it stop it
do you just suplex me yeah oh how do you
like that bicep kick bicycle kicked you
into the air oh you totally missed now I
don't think I missed that
Oh kicks we kick master Oh you jumped
over me what's gonna take master stuff
oh you wanna play huh oh I missed oh my
goodness don't you die now Casey cos
you're doing so good against Isaac yeah
he's out of here he's that oh oh you did
you did
oh my goodness
dad you're gay now you're dead oh my god
when do you ever die how come you don
cake master I just keep doing the same
thing over and over I feel like whoa I
think mommy's texting me all game we're
having uh some technical difficulties
when there's nothing wrong we're all
done now I'm exhausted
you can go Deena with the people
Thursday nights TIFF goes to JK news
well I go to jakey news to try
separately because I had to leave
earlier so I could pick them up and TIFF
is the host of the show so she needs to
stay obviously so we have our wet fun
nights yeah and our game nights are
bonding nights is that me doing that to
you who's winning right now who's doing
the crazy stuff
why am I on fire is that a good thing
yeah it's a good thing oh you got
nothing you got nothing
oh no fun no fun no jump jump jump jump
jump jump jump jump jump my - the motion
all right your buddy
oh no well is that great like a girl oh
I have glowing stuff around me dude you
can't defeat me ah why can't this
glowing they help me get you get me
closer
are you gotta press B he's your special
ability well guys thank you for watching
watching this is like Isaac's like
practice thank you for watching please
like down below and subscribe to to Finn
cakes and future Channel and future
champ whatever it may be called yeah
[Music]